ordinaire de l'histoire de notre pays
parce que les semaines et les mois que
nous vivons tout le monde voit bien
qu'elles seront dans les livres
d'histoire on a connu des années des
années de longues périodes de glaciation
chacun resté sur ses positions
et puis les choses se sont mises à
bouger ça a été encore répété il ya une
minute par philippe bilger et jean
claude casanova à cette tribune
l'alternance à la tête de la france pour
les raisons qui ont été largement
rappelé et est à mes yeux nécessité
parce que les tensions de venait-elle
l'impasse était si fermé que
l'alternance était un besoin du pays et
les thèmes d'affrontements et est si
dangereux que cela à mon avis s'imposer
vous savez que j'ai eu tout au long de
ma vie des relations relativement
difficile avec alain mac est un homme
très intelligent a toujours été de son
avis ni dans le fond ni dans la forme
au début du mois de juillet ou à la fin
du mois de juin alain minc a donné une
interview aux échos que j'ai trouvé
absolument juste et dans cette interview
il dit ceci que je cite exactement mon
sentiment est que cette alternance est
une bénédiction pour la société et une
malédiction pour l'économie si je
continue la citation si nicolas sarkozy
avait été réélu le pays aurait été très
difficile à gouverner
cela aurait engendré une frustration
terrible
dans une partie de la population et un
jour ou l'autre cela aurait débouché sur
des éruptions de violence l'élection de
françois hollande apaiser les brûlures
et puis il n'ya pas de démocratie
vivante sans alternance politique
en revanche at il ajouté oui je suis
très inquiet pour l'état de l'économie
et bien ce double jugement positif d'un
côté négatif de l'autre rassurant en
même temps que inquiétant à mes yeux est
justifié et je le partage
la situation du pouvoir est devenu et va
devenir périlleuse et controversé et
pour de bonnes et de mauvaises raisons
aujourd'hui françois hollande est
critique crée parfois raillé et de
manière à mes yeux parfois excessives
ce qu'il admire et hier n'ont pas de
mots assez durs aujourd'hui et
l'hebdomadaire dominant de la gauche
française n'a pas hésité à utiliser en
couverture le mot nul
en réalité c'est ne pas voir le dilemme
qui est celui du pouvoir aujourd'hui et
de la résolution de ce dilemme dépend le
redressement du pays
françois hollande l'autre jour sur tf1 a
décrit une action politique que pour ma
part s'il l'a suis je trouve courageuse
et que de plus je trouverais fondé s'il
parvient à la mener à terme
il a décrit cinq grandes réformes 5
grandes directions une loi de finances
qui diminue de 10 milliards la dépense
publique
le traité européen qui impose dans la
durée à d'autres pays des disciplines
que jusqu'à maintenant il refusait la
création d'une autorité indépendante de
la dépense publique placée auprès de la
cour des comptes qui empêchera sur le
long terme les bricolages auquel les
gouvernants se livrent régulièrement
avec les hypothèses de croissance et les
chiffres gonflés les chiffres gonflés
quand ils sont bons et minorée
quand ils sont mauvais la réforme du
droit du travail et la réforme du
financement de la sécu pour qu'elle pèse
moins lourd sur le travail ne croyez pas
que ce soit rien ni même peu de choses
je ne peux m'empêcher de sourire quand
je vois les commentateurs dire mais ils
vont pas assez loin
ces cinq chantiers ils sont parmi les
plus impressionnants de ceux qui ont été
programmées ces dernières décennies et
de surcroît ces cinq chantiers
s'ils sont effectivement conduit par un
gouvernement de gauche
il annonce malgré les obstacles qui se
lèveront un changement intellectuelle de
la gauche française que beaucoup de
leaders du centre et pas mal de leaders
de droite de la droite républicaine
attendait ou disait attendre depuis des
décennies
souvenez vous dans nos rangs et pas
seulement dans nos rangs dans les rangs
de toutes les familles modérée du pays
on disait lacan jeu française n'a jamais
fait comme la gauche allemande son bad
godesberg le jour où ils auront le
courage de faire leur bac de desberg
alors ce jour là nous les regarderons
d'un autre oeil
alors battre vos dsb comme vous le savez
c'est le nom de cette ville allemande où
se tint le congrès du spd les
socialistes allemands 1959
c'est la date historique à laquelle le
spd répudie le marxisme et accepte
l'économie de liberté et d'une certaine
manière pour qu'ils voient le long terme
le plan schröder l'agenda 2010 qui a
constitué le socle des grandes réformes
qui ont conduit l'allemagne où elle se
trouve aujourd'hui
eh bien c'était entièrement en germe
dans bad godesberg
et bien si vous réfléchissez à ce que
rend inéluctable
'l'annonce des cinq chantiers que je
viens de citer devant vous du président
de la république c'est un bad godesberg
en direct on ne voit pas fait pas
attention parce que très souvent les
paysages historique échappe à ceux là
même qui les vivent
vous savez que fabrice à waterloo voyez
pas ce qui se passait nous si nous
essayons de prendre un peu de recul
alors nous voyons que un grand
changement est peut-être en germe
parce que depuis des décennies
l'idéologie de la gauche française
c'était la dépense publique
la relance par la consommation la
multiplication des postes de
fonctionnaires dans tous les secteurs de
l'activité depuis des décennies son
idéologie c'était l'intervention de
l'état et tous ceux qui avaient essayé
de briser cette idéologie qui étaient
nos amis nos cousins diront certains moi
j'ai presque tendance à dire nos frères
et jean marie van lerberghe ne me
démentira pas sur ce sujet ceux de la
deuxième gauche comme on disait michel
rocard et jacques delors qui ont été
pour nous d des repères positif dans le
paysage politique français
eh bien ceux qui ont essayé de briser
cette idéologie il s'était cassé les
dents sur ce béton durcit alors
regardons bien les choses
si ces cinq chantiers sont menés à terme
et comme vous l'entendez je ne
sous-estime en rien la difficulté de
cette oeuvre politique est probablement
historique ni les conséquences qu'elle
va à voir si elle est menée à son terme
alors c'est un dégel qui se sera produit
s'il y arrive
car il existe un certain nombre un
nombre certain de résistance et de
réticences et de réserve qui vont venir
se mettre en travers de cette volonté
que je crois pourtant fondées première
résistance la plus importante sans doute
c'est que de ces grands choix pendant la
campagne de l'élection présidentielle
les français n'ont pas été averties et
pour nous le contrat de gouvernement
c'est dans la campagne qu'il s'écrit
alors il est des gens pour penser que
les promesses n'engagent que ceux qui
les reçoivent
c'est charles pasqua qui avait théorisé
cette phrase avec l'accent les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les reçoivent
mais nous nous pensons que c'est
exactement le contraire et que dans une
campagne notamment présidentielles les
promesses sont fondatrices de quelque
chose et voilà pourquoi j'ai choisi tout
au long de ma vie politique d'être du
côté inconfortable peut-être même
périlleux de ce qu'ils disent
invariablement la vérité au peuple des
citoyens
devant vous c'était à gien lorsque jean
peyrelevade m'a rejoint il a dit ceci
qui n'a jamais quitté mon esprit il a
dit je ne sais pas si on peut gagner en
disant la vérité mais je suis sûr qu'on
ne pourra pas gouverner si on ne l'a pas
dit
auparavant pendant la campagne
présidentielle et bien notre fierté et
notre marque d'identité c'est d'avoir
tenu cette promesse de dire sur tous les
sujets dont dépend l'avenir national la
vérité aux français et cela sera le
socle de notre relation avec eux dans
les moins et les années qui viennent
or c'est le contraire qui a été choisi
par les vainqueurs par les finalistes
même c'est le contraire qui a été
choisie dire au peuple des électeurs
voyez que je distingue les électeurs et
les citoyens dans cette période parce
qu'on les regarde
nota comme des citoyens responsables
mais comme des électeurs dont on veut ap
la voit donc dire au peuple des
électeurs des promesses agréable évoqué
des engagements séduisant et éluder ce
qui va faire l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
les efforts à conduire et à porter
c'était la partition du parti socialiste
pendant toute la campagne
entre nous c'était aussi la partition de
nicolas sarkozy je me souviens de trois
affirmations première la crise est
derrière nous deuxièmement les économies
elles ont été décidées
il y en aura pas d'autre choisir et
troisièmement je ne créerait pas d'
impôt nouveau
eh bien ces trois affirmations même
temps si vous les mettez en relation et
en systèmes vous voyez bien que
évidemment elles sont constitutives
aller d'une dissimulation de la vérité
mais ce fut bien entendu le cas de la
campagne de françois hollande
alors comprenez moi bien je parle ici de
ce que les français ont compris ou plus
exactement de ce qu'on a donné à
comprendre français et je ne prétends
pas bien entendu vous savez les
rédacteurs de programmes sont habiles
qu'il n'y ait pas eu ici ou là une
phrase glissée dissimulé de manière
qu'un jour on puisse l'opposé à un
étonnement des citoyens devant son camp
leur propose mais l'essentiel donc le
fond de la campagne ce que les français
avaient entendu c'était que c'était avec
le vote pour ceux qui l'ont emporté le
parti socialiste c'était le retour des
beaux jours les changements à nouveau
les postes est à nous
l'augmentation des allocations et ceci
est aujourd'hui l'obstacle principal le
caillou dans la chaussure d'un peuple
qui est saisissant s'y attendre vraiment
par l'impressionnante falaise qu'on a
dressé devant lui qu'on va lui demander
de gravir et un deuxième obstacle
s'ajoute au premier je le dis rapidement
parce que j'ai beaucoup insisté dans les
dents les mois de campagne sur ce sujet
c'est que autant que des efforts
importants vont être demandés en même
temps des décisions sont annoncées qui
sont déraisonnables
alors je vous le dis comme ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale pour
exemple il est déraisonnable d'annoncer
qu'on va recruter l'année prochaine 40
2000 enseignants nouveau l'an dernier il
y avait seize mille postes au concours
il ya plusieurs centaines de postes qui
n'ont pas pu être pourvus parce que les
jurys ont considéré que les candidats
n'avaient pas le niveau
plusieurs centaines en mathématiques
plusieurs centaines en lettres
classiques
plusieurs centaines dans des sur des
postes de langues vivantes bref comment
voulez vous qu'on passe en une seule
année de 16000 qui n'ont pas été
remplies à 42000 alors ou bien on va
recruter des candidats faible et ultra
faible ou bien même on ne remplira pas
les postes et ça n'est pas rendre
service à un pays que de le gouverner
par à-coups aussi brutaux et s'il y
avait une justification de l'attitude
politique du centre démocratique en
france depuis des années et des
décennies c'est qu'ils demandent qu'on
gouverne pour le long terme avec
réflexion avec raison et pas qu'on fasse
du gouvernement du pays
des à coups brutaux qui ne font que le
déstabiliser et à terme le desservir
et bien entendu vous savez bien que pour
nous c'est un danger de croire que l'on
peut redresser les finances d'un pays en
faisant appel principalement à l'impôt
nous avons toujours dit pendant la
campagne présidentielle qu'il fallait
trouver un équilibre un équilibre à 50
50 entre l'impôt pour améliorer les
rentrées du budget et la baisse des
dépenses publiques
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on est en
train de faire ce qu'on est en train de
faire à l'heure actuelle c'est 27
milliards pour l'impôt et 10 milliards
pour la baisse de la dépense publique si
on y arrive ça n'est pas le bon
équilibre et c'est d'ailleurs impossible
de le maintenir dans le temps lorsque
vous n'imaginez pas qu'on va pouvoir
couche après couche réaugmenter le la
pression fiscale sur les ménages et sur
les entreprises qui va être évidemment
extrêmement forte et donc de ce point de
vue là je considère qu'on n'a pas trouvé
l'équilibré et qu'il n'y aura réellement
baisse des dépenses que les jours que le
jour où on comprendra que la baisse des
dépenses publiques ne peut intervenir
que si on commence par une politique
volontaire de réforme de l'état c'est
l'état en france qui est selon moins mal
organisées souvent autobloquant j'en
dirai un mot dans une minute et que
c'est la réforme de l'état qui seule
peut nous conduire à sortir de la
situation qui ne se justifient pas d'un
pays qui a des points de dépenses
publiques de plus que son principal
voisin principal concurrent avec un
niveau de vie dont le moins qu'on puisse
dire qu'il est qu'il est du même gabarit
et donc de ce point de vue là il ya des
orientations que je trouve incohérente
avec des objectifs qui ont été fixés
mais s'il maintient les orientations et
s'ils corrigent modifie les incohérences
alors je dis que il faut suivre
attentivement la politique que fera le
gouvernement il aura fait vrai utile et
il méritera qu'on le dise parce que je
voudrais qu'on ne se trompe pas sur ce
point c'est plus difficile d'aller dans
la bonne direction de ram et parfois à
contre courant que de laisser aller les
choses
cela demande de convaincre et pour
convaincre il faut comprendre et faire
passer les arguments et des sentiments
il faut que les peuples d il faut que le
peuple des citoyens voient que leurs
dirigeants sont tout entiers investis
dans cette action avec eux et pas loin
d'eux et qu'ils sont désintéressés
sensible en même temps que déterminée
c'est plus difficile d'aller dans cette
direction mais ce n'est pas impossible
je veux signaler à votre attention et
peut-être à vos applaudissements
ce qui est en train de se passer en
italie parce que je considère que mario
monti en italie donne à l'europe toute
entière la preuve que l'on peut
convaincre et rassembler même en
conduisant la politique la plus
exigeante et la plus contraignante par
rigueur morale et désintéressement et je
trouve que s'il ya un homme qui
aujourd'hui rend service à la cause qui
est la nôtre
ceux qui veulent une gestion équilibrée
dans le long terme
un soutien à une société entreprenante
et positive et la construction d'une
europe qui sera fière d'elle-même et pas
constamment déstabilisation c'est ce que
fait mario monti en italie et ça mérite
qu'on le soutienne
mais on va découvrir dans les semaines
qui viennent si je ne me trompe pas qui
est un obstacle plus embarrassant encore
c'est que la majorité nécessaire au
soutien de cette politique qu'il faut
appeler par son nom c'est à dire une
politique réformiste cette majorité pour
l'instant n'existe pas on a bâti la
majorité du changement mais on n'a pas
bâti la majorité de la réforme et pour
une grande partie
on arrête on a même bâti la majorité du
changement sur le refus de la réforme et
on vient de le voir sous nos yeux avec
l'officialisation de la facture sur le
traité européen dont jean marc ayrault a
eu l'honnêteté à la télévision de
reconnaître qu'il était mot pour mot
celui qui avait été négociée par nicolas
sarkozy et que les français avaient
entendu promettre qu'on allait changer
modifier et que c'était évidemment pas
celui là comme adopterait et pourtant
dans ce changement réformiste qui est en
train d'intervenir sous nos yeux et
pourtant
l'adoption de ce traité est au coeur de
l'action gouvernementale
je le crois nous le croyons pour la
plupart d'entre nous mais une partie de
la majorité ne le crois pas
eh bien je pense qu'il faut que nous
contribuons nous a expliqué que les
dispositions de ce traité il aurait
fallu les respecter en tout état de
cause même si elle n'avait pas été
demandé par nos partenaires européens
comme garantie à la mise en place d'une
politique de solidarité responsable nos
partenaires européens sans doute ont
besoin de cette garantie et je sais
juste et parmi jeu les billets hier soir
parmi les réorientations de ces derniers
mois que j'ai approuvé il y a le
rééquilibrage que françois hollande a
imposé à l'union européenne
en sortant de du duo ou du condominium
que il avait souhaité imposer avec
angela merkel ce qu'on appelait merkozy
avec deux qui décident et les autres qui
obéissent et par exemple en rendant à
l'italie sa place au coeur de la volonté
européenne et vous observerez si vous y
réfléchissez que france allemagne italie
suffit d'ajouter le benelux pour avoir
les 6 de la constitution originelle de
l'europe et l'espagne d'une certaine
manière on l'est puisque elle a 7 ans y
était associé évidemment décision à
prendre mais je veux dire à ceux qui
mettent en doute le traité européen
si le traité de la règle d'or européenne
n'existait pas il aurait fallu inventer
une règle d'or nationale s'il n'y avait
pas la règle d'or européen est fort et
il faudrait une règle d'or française
j'ai été le premier des responsables
politique en france à défendre à
proposer une telle idée puis longtemps
depuis plus de dix ans or hier
hier nous avons appris que la dette
française avait dépassé 91 % de la
production annuelle du pays
91% on était à 85 % il ya à peine
quelques mois ou une année
ça veut dire qu'on court à grands pas à
grande vitesse vers les 100 % de dette
par rapport à la production nationale du
pays la totalité de la production de
toutes les entreprises de tous les
artisans de toutes les factures de tous
les commerçants français pendant la
totalité d'une année c'est ça qui est
aujourd'hui l'endettement de l'état de
la puissance publique au sens large et
bien je vous dis que ceci est
insoutenable et que ce n'est pas pour
nos partenaires européens que nous
devons faire l'effort
c'est pas pour les autres c'est pour
nous mêmes parce que courir depuis des
années depuis plus d'une décennie à
cette catastrophe qui interviendra au
moment où les doutes sur la capacité de
la france à rembourser sa dette
feront exploser les taux d'intérêt du
pays
cette évidemment condamné notre pays a
beaucoup plus d'angoise a beaucoup plus
de restrictions a beaucoup plus
d'efforts fiscale et à l'incapacité de
se projeter dans l'avenir et même à
souffrir dans son indépendance parce que
l' équilibre financier c'est
l'indépendance du pays et son influence
et tout le monde est coresponsable bien
entendu l'ump parce qu'il était au
pouvoir depuis dix ans mais même dans
l'opposition elle porte une
responsabilité très importante à la fin
des années 90 et au début des années
2000 un vent de croissance aussitôt
après la dissolution de 97 à souffler
sur l'europe sur le monde et sur la
france c'était des alizés qui gonflait
nos voiles et le gouvernement jospin
avait eu la prudence de ne pas tout
dépensé des ressources nouvelles que
cette croissance lui apporter et que
croyez vous qu'il arriva
et bien c'est jacques chirac président
de la république de la cohabitation qui
a mis en demeure le gouvernement d'avoir
un dépenser ce qu'il appela alors la
cagnotte que jospin avait mises de côté
et bien ceci a été une mauvaise action
contre l' équilibre de notre pays et
contre son avenir parce que la règle
c'est que c'est quand ça va bien qu'il
faut faire des économies pour avoir des
capacités d'action quand ça va mal et
c'est parce que nous avons manqué à
cette règle depuis trente ans que nous
sommes dans la situation où nous sommes
aujourd'hui et que nous avons eu
l'honneur de combattre devant les
français et en leur nom
donc c'est un traité qui n'est pas
seulement pour l'europe mais c'est un
traité évidemment pour nous mêmes et je
me réjouis j'espère qu'il va être votée
et je me réjouis en même temps qu'on
pose la question de la capacité de la
france de la capacité de la france à
entreprendre investir le mot
compétitivité qui est sur toutes les
lèvres ce point j'aimais beaucoup
raymond barre qui aimait beaucoup le mot
compétitivité
ça prouve que les amis de nos amis sont
pas toujours nos amis parce que moi j'ai
moins le mot compétitivité qui est très
abstrait pour beaucoup de français
moi je préfère d'autres mots que le pays
soit fort qu'il est un élan qu'il puisse
en effet être fort dans la compétition
du monde c'est très heureux que cette
notion cette réflexion soit désormais au
premier rang des responsabilités très
heureux souvent dans ce débat on met en
avant le coût du travail et c'est la
première chose que l'on place sur la
table pour moi je ne crois pas l'une
d'entre nous tout à l'heure à donner un
exemple je ne crois pas que le coût du
travail soit le facteur essentiel de la
compétitivité au moins dans les marges
de fluctuation qu'on pourra trouver en
répartissant autrement les charges des
entreprises c'est-à-dire comme jean
claude casanova l'a dit en faisant peser
les charges des entreprises sur les
consommateurs et d'une certaine manière
les travailleurs les salariés et les
consommateurs et leurs familles très
largement ce sont les mêmes donc je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait un sésame ouvre
toi
dans ce une répartition réellement
différente des charges sociales sur les
entreprises
si on y arrive tant mieux je veux vous
rappeler ça vous rappellera des
souvenirs anciens que j'avais proposée
autrefois que si on mettait en place la
taxe sur les transactions financières
la taxe sur les mouvements financiers
peut-être même la taxe sur une taxe très
légère sur chacun des mouvements
financiers à l'intérieur du pays
on aurait pu affecter cette taxe à la
baisse des charges sociales
quand j'entends le gouvernement dira il
ya d'autres pistes
je me demande s'il n'y a pas aussi dans
leur esprit des pistes de cet ordre mais
en tout cas et 2 et de ce point de vue
là c'est bien qu'on y réfléchisse mais
je ne crois pas encore une fois que ce
soit l'élément essentiel et j'ai pour ça
un indice que vous avez aussi c'est la
situation de ceux qui nous entourent
alors je vais pas parler de l'allemagne
pour une fois mais je demande qu'on
regarde la suisse est un pays de haut
niveau de vie dans lequel j'ai pas
l'impression que la misère règne qui
paie des salaires beaucoup plus élevés
que les nôtres où le coût du travail lui
même est plus élevé que chez nous est
cependant la suisse exporte à tout va à
telle enseigne que la banque centrale
suisse qui sait faire ce qu'il faut est
obligé naturellement de faire baisser
artificiellement le coût du franc suisse
parce qu'autrement ils créent vrai les
plafonds c'est donc pour moi la preuve
qu'il existe une capacité de compétition
une force de compétition et un élan qui
ne dépend pas uniquement du coût du
travail en tout cas il sera très
intéressant de suivre les travaux des
partenaires sociaux sur le sujet des
charges qui pèsent sur le travail mais
je pense qu'il y à beaucoup d'autres
pistes à suivre
je pense par exemple que il est bien des
charges bien des contraintes bien des
contrôles qui empêche les entreprises
les familles et les grands secteurs de
notre pays de vivre et de se développer
j'ai été frappé dans un domaine qui
m'est chère du récent rapport de
l'académie des sciences sur la recherche
en france qui écrit noir sur blanc que
le diagnostic ou qui reprend le même
diagnostic que nous avons porté pendant
la campagne présidentielle et qui se dit
en mots très simples
ça n'est pas principalement de moyens
que la recherche française moyen nouveau
que la recherche française a besoin mais
il est urgent de laisser aux chercheurs
aux chercheurs le temps et la
disponibilité de poursuivre leurs
recherches
il est urgent d'arrêter de pompey leur
force leur capacité leur vitalité à
compléter d'innombrables dossier jamais
achevé tous dirigés vers l'évaluation et
l'évaluation de l'évaluation laisser les
chercheurs travaillent et laisser les
français travailler entreprendre vivre
laisser les entreprises françaises
travailler entreprendre et vivre alléger
leurs contraintes alléger leur contrôle
de manière que oui elle trouve la force
de la compétition et c'est là que se
trouve pour moi l'essentiel du travail a
conduit
sortez de la société de défiance de
contrôle de blocage pour entrer dans la
société de confiance et de liberté c'est
un changement d'époque
c'est un changement d'esprit dont nous
avons besoin et ça ne coûte pas ça
rapporte
il n'est pas un secteur de notre pays
qui ne doivent être concernés par cette
révolution des esprits logement
l'intégration l'éducation la recherche
l'entreprise et ses rapports avec
l'administration
l'administration dans son rapport avec
les autres administrations parce que la
sécu etc
partout on a l'impression d'un état
autobloquant ou les freins se serre où
les décisions ne peuvent pas être prises
où il faut d éternité et des dossiers
constamment à reprendre et des documents
constamment à fournir et à fournir à
nouveau et qui empêche la vitalité de la
france de trouver son plein
épanouissement et de trouver sa pleine
efficacité et bien je suis sûr que là il
y a évidemment beaucoup de progrès à
faire en compétitivité et c'est pourquoi
il est tellement important dans un
domaine parallèle que le droit du
travail soit mis sur la table parce que
là je suis sûr qu'on peut agir pour
faciliter l'entrée dans le travail en
sachant que facilités d'entrée dans le
travail c'est aussi facilité quand il le
faut la sortie la transition
la formation dans des phases où les
choses vont moins bien pour l'entreprise
là on peut agir effectivement pour
améliorer la souplesse alléger les
contraintes sans baisser les salaires et
jusqu'à maintenant c'est là que se passe
là
le grand mouvement la révolution
intellectuelle dont nous parlions
jusqu'à maintenant la gauche politique
et la gauche syndicale paraissait a
bouté sur cette question et c'est une
bonne nouvelle que l'alternance est
permis qu'on laborde dans un état
d'esprit nouveau j'ai été très frappée
robert par la jeune femme de la cfdt qui
est venu s'exprimer sur cette tribune
avec beaucoup de sens positif et
réaliste acceptant d'envisager une
première dans l'histoire syndicale
française que oui on reprenne tout ça
tranquillement qu'on le mette sur la
table et qu'il allait bien falloir
conduire les évolutions nécessaires pour
que le réel soit désormais aborder avec
plus de deux volontés positive qu'il ne
l'a été jusqu'à maintenant je ne doute
pas qu'il y aura des réticences et des
blocages et il faudra passer outre pour
construire l'état d'esprit nouveau dont
la france va avoir besoin l'état
d'esprit nouveau il doit aussi vaincre
les blocages que fait naître la
politique
la majorité va changer au contact du
réel mais je veux dire ceci devant vous
l'opposition aussi est responsable de
l'avenir majorité opposition
indépendante ou son responsable ensemble
sont co responsables de l'avenir c'est
la vision que nous portons et qui fait
du mouvement démocrate
une avant-garde comme je lé dit l'autre
jour à l'ouverture de ces journées une
proposition nouvelle dans la vie
politique française
je n'ai pas si je ne sais pas si vous
avez suivi la convention démocrate
américaine bill clinton a fait un
formidable discours que je vous
conseille de regarder et dont si vous
voulez on pourra mettre la traduction
sur notre site
parce que il parlait bien entendu en
termes très chaleureux et d'autant plus
chaleureux qu'ils devaient surmonter une
longue histoire commune
il parlait en termes très chaleureux de
barack obama et même de michelle obama
pour la note pour sa nomination comme
porte-drapeau des démocrates américains
mais au fond du discours il y avait une
orientation politique une conception de
la politique qui concernait pas
seulement les démocrates américains
mais les démocrates sur toute la planète
et il a formulé cette loi qui contredit
et c'est aussi valable en france que
partout ailleurs
il a formulé cette loi qui contredit
l'agressivité la ligne agressive de la
droite du parti républicain
il habille la coopération portent plus
de fruits que le conflit perpétuel et
bien la coopération l'entente la
recherche du consensus sur les sujets
importants entre les grands courants
politiques qui font une démocratie entre
majorité et opposition
cette coopération marche mieux que la
recherche perpétuelle de l'affrontement
que le déchaînement des passions
agressive que l'exaspération voulu des
détestations
particulièrement particulièrement dans
un pays en crise et c'est une conception
de la démocratie et de la société qui
s'énonce l'a particulièrement dans un
pays en crise parce que rien n'est plus
facile que de faire flamber
l'exaspération la mésentente que de
souffler sur les braises et rien au ciné
plus néfastes et n'est plus dangereux
rien et au bout du compte plus mortelle
pour un pays spécialement dans les temps
difficiles et hélas rien n'est bien
entendu plus profitable électoralement
rien ne rapporte plus de voix mais je
veux vous dire ceci qui concerne notre
vocation de mouvement démocrate il est
deux sortes de femmes et d'hommes
politiques
il y a ceux qui pensent qu'il faut
d'abord chercher des voix et il y a ceux
qui pensent qu'il faut d'abord chercher
le bien du pays le bien commun le bien
des gens et qu'au bout du compte c'est
par ce chemin là qu'on trouvera les voix
des steam et de respect et d'adhésion
et quand il ya contradiction quand ils
arrivent dans les moments graves qu'il y
ait contradiction entre la recherche des
voies et la recherche du bien commun
pour le pays alors leur vient où il faut
choisir son camp
et permettez moi de vous le dire avec
affection et avec émotion quand il a
fallu choisir
j'ai choisi après ma dernière émission
il ya huit jours sur europe1 importants
responsables politiques d'ailleurs
socialiste m'a envoyé par sms une phrase
de churchill que je voudrais soumettre à
votre réflexion
ils cherchent ils disaient il y a deux
sortes de responsables politiques
qui prépare la prochaine élection et
ceux qui préparent la prochaine
génération
les premiers sont des politiques les
seconds sont des hommes d'état
vous qui
eh bien nous avons ces jours ci nous
nous sommes beaucoup interrogé sur
l'identité du mouvement démocrate
et bien ne cherchez pas point nous
sommes ceux qui cherchons la coopération
entre les grands courants de pensée du
pays plutôt que l'exaspération des
conflits et des affrontements
nous sommes ceux qui prépareront la
prochaine génération plutôt que la
prochaine élection
et c'est pourquoi
et c'est pourquoi nous ne céderons
jamais devant ceux qui cherchent à faire
flamber les malaises pour les
transformer en un ch'ti tous ceux d'un
bord ou de l'autre qui se disent
régulièrement décomplexée
tous ceux qui prétendent dire tout haut
ce que tout le monde pense tout bas
tout ce dont la stratégie réfléchie
méditer à fins électorales
parce que c'est bien sûr de gagner des
voix qu'il s'agit tout ce qu'ils veulent
pour cela que la braise qui s'éteignait
se ranime que l'étincelle se transforme
en flammèches que le feu gagne pour
qu'ils se trouvent eux porté par l'air
chaud de l' incendie
il faut leur rappeler que ce feu là
c'est un pays qu'il brûle c'est une
nation qui ravagent ce sont les enfants
qu'il sépare et jette les uns contre les
autres au nom de l'origine ou au nom de
la religion ou au nom de la couleur de
la peau qu'on veut mettre en avant
qu'elle soit noir ou bistre ou blanches
et bien nous qui savons parfaitement nos
citoyens et les élus qui sont ici et les
maires que bien sûr ça brûle souvent
chez nous dans les quartiers et entre
communautés et qu'on se regarde du coin
de l'oeil mais que parfois on ne peut
pas se voir en peinture et que les
minorités sont ciblés
quelles que soient les minorités les
musulmans ici les juifs là les chrétiens
plus souvent qu'on ne croit quand ils
osent encore se montrer mais si les
responsables publics font de ces
tensions par la force de la parole
politique
un signe de mobilisation d'une partie de
la france contre l'autre alors
particulièrement en temps de crise le
feu se propage et la question est alors
est-ce que tu acceptes le feu est-ce que
tu profites du feu ou est-ce que tu
combats le feu nous sommes ceux qui
combattent ont le feu nous sommes ce
chose qu'ils ne mettront jamais poste
ted l'instant c'est ce qui dans la
dernière période mais c'est pas tout
toutant a fait que je combats que
combattons ceux qui recherchent des
accords souterrain et peut-être un jour
apparent avec l'extrémisme et notamment
avec l'extrême droite
c'est ce qui fait que nous combattons
ceux qui ciblent les patrons dont la
société française comme s'ils étaient
des ennemis ou les riches entre
guillemets sont qu'on sache très bien où
commence la l'état de riches qui à qui
il faudrait faire rendre gorge
je vous le dis pour un pays
particulièrement en temps de crise dure
la division est mortel et l'unité est la
seule chance dans un pays
particulièrement en temps de crise
l'unité est un devoir et c'est ce devoir
là que nous avons l'intention de
défendre
et c'est précisément parce qu'il est
plus difficile de dire la vérité que de
multiplier les mensonges c'est
précisément parce qu'il est plus
difficile d'obtenir l'unité que de
cultiver la division que nous avons
choisi de construire ensemble le
mouvement démocrate en france
et c'est pour cela que je conteste la
bipolarisation parce qu'au nom de la
logique des camps elle justifie tous les
excès des plus dures de son temps elle
ferme les yeux sur leurs dérives au nom
du pas d'ennemi à droite ou du pas
d'ennemis à gauche et au bout du compte
ça revient à ce que c'est cela ceux qui
cherchent la division qui en viennent à
régner sur les esprits c'est pourquoi
nous qui sommes les démocrates en france
nous aimons aussi l'idée de centre parce
que le centre c'est ce qui se bat
toujours contre les extrêmes
le centre c'est le lieu où l'on refuse
de regarder ses concurrents comme des
adversaires et ses adversaires comme des
ennemis ça n'a rien d'angélique c'est
pragmatique parce que ce ce sont ceux
qui ont une certaine vu de l'histoire
des hommes parce qu'il préfère la
conciliation à l'agression et c'est
pourquoi nous défendons et nous servons
l'idée de l'unité du centre pas
aujourd'hui en 2012 seulement pas
épisodiquement pas accidentellement
toujours quand on nous expliquait car
nombreux étaient ceux qui expliquaient
qu'il fallait que le centre
disparaissent pour se fondre au sein
d'un parti unique l'ump nous défendions
l'existence du centre et j'allais à
toulouse
et j'allais à toulouse dire vous dites
que nous pensons tous la même chose si
nous pensons tous la même chose c'est
que nous ne pensons plus rien quand on
nous expliquait qu'il fallait que le
centre se scinde parce qu'il fallait
qu'une fois pour toutes il fut
clairement à droite nous défendions son
intégrité et son unité et son
originalité et aujourd'hui nous disons
si le centre existe alors le centre est
un
il n'y a pas de centre droit de centre
gauche ou de centre ailleurs le centre
n'a pas besoin d'adjectifs
le centre n'a pas besoin qu'on leur
envoie sur le côté parce que sans ça
c'est sa vocation qui disparaît et c'est
son être même qui se dissout et ceux qui
j'ai oublié un fait important le centre
n'a pas besoin d'adjectifs il n'a pas
besoin qu'on leur envoie sur le côté et
le centre doit se définir par lui même
et pas par rapport aux autres
et ceux qui en viennent à dire que le
centre doit forcément être à droite
je rappelle que c'était aussi ce qu'ils
disent est ce que disait à gauche
nos adversaires étaient même une formule
fameuse de mitterrand que vous savez
donc ceux qui disent que le centre doit
forcément être à droite ils disent une
seule chose ils disent que pour eux le
centre n'existe pas vraiment eh bien je
veux dire en votre nom et avec
l'expérience que nous pouvons travailler
avec la droite et nous l'avons fait
souvent et je les fais souvent si la
droite est compatible avec ce que nous
croyons dans son projet et dans ses
intentions et dans sa manière d'être
tout à l'heure philippe bilger en
appeler à une droite honorable et
républicaine avec celle là il n'y a
aucun problème
nous pouvons travailler il n'y a pas de
difficultés
et de la même manière nous pouvons
travailler avec la gauche si la gauche
est compatible avec ce que nous croyons
si l'évolution qui se dessine dont je ne
suis pas sûr qu'elle aille à son terme
dont j'espère qu'elle va se confirmer
se dessine alors oui nous pouvons être
co responsable de l'avenir du pays
nous pouvons nous allier
mais nous ne devons pas nous dissoudre
il n'y a pas il n'ya pas d'allégeance
obligatoire il n'y a pas d'alliance
obligatoire parce que l'alliance
obligatoire c'est pas l'alliance c'est
une soumission
spécialement quand on prétend obligé le
centre a renoncé à son histoire à son
passé ceci est un message personnel il y
a en moins une personne en france qui ne
devrait pas prétendre que le centre doit
être à droite c'est le président du
parti radical parce que le parti radical
c'est le plus ancien je ne dis pas le
plus vieux c'est le plus ancien des
partis politiques français
il a une grande histoire profondément
lié à la république
une histoire dont tous les républicains
dont - comme républicains je me sens
fier et solidaire mais cette histoire du
parti radical
elle s'est déroulée pour l'essentiel non
pas à droite mais à gauche et c'est nier
l'histoire du parti radical que de
prétendre qu'il faut effacer rayer d'un
trait de plume la grande histoire
républicaine française pour la projeter
uniquement sur la drac
tout le monde a le droit de soutenir une
thèse comme ça tout le monde mais pas
ceux qui ont la charge de l'histoire
actuelle du parti radical parce que les
héritiers de clemenceau et d'edouard
herriot et même sans remonter aussi loin
avant la guerre les parties de jean zay
de jean moulin de pierre mendès-france
de jean-jacques servan-schreiber
ils n'ont pas le droit de rayer cette
histoire parce que c'est un peu de la
nôtre qu'il porte et nous avons le droit
de la défendre devant te l'autre jour le
jeune secrétaire général du parti
radical pour que j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie après mon offre de démarche
unitaire il a publié un communiqué pour
dire jamais nous radicaux n'accepteront
de cartel des gauches et bien les
historiens c'est une chose formidable
eh bien j'avais bien envie de l'appeler
ou plutôt de lui rappeler que le cartel
des gauches
c'était à l'initiative du parti radical
et qu' edouard herriot le plus grand
radical d'avant la guerre en était le
chef
et s'il le faut je suis prêt amicalement
à défendre la grande histoire du parti
radical y compris contre ses héritiers
si leur paie à l'esprit dit être
infidèle
et vous voyez pourquoi vous touchez du
doigt précisément la raison pour
laquelle un mouvement politique digne de
ce nom il doit se définir par rapport à
lui même par rapport à sa propre
histoire
l'histoire de la république pour les
républicains l'histoire du radicalisme
l'histoire de la démocratie chrétienne
pour moi et pour beaucoup d'entre nous
l'histoire de la social-démocratie un
jour l'histoire de l'écologie politique
j'affirme que la politique aussi ou peu
j'affirme que la politique est aussi une
question de fidélité et la première des
fidélités politique c'est la fidélité à
soi-même à ce qu'on croit à ce qu'on
aime à ce qu'on est
c'est à ce prix que vous pouvez vous
faire entendre c'est comme ça qu'on vous
écoutera
et c'est comme ça en étant fidèle à
soi-même fort dans ses convictions
solides dans ses idées c'est comme ça
que nous ferons les élus que méritent
les idées que nous défendons
et donc j'affirme en votre nom que le
centre ne sera fort que lorsqu'il ce que
lorsqu'il sera ou plus exactement il ne
sera fort que lorsqu'il acceptera d'être
totalement unie et qu'il ne sera unie
que lorsque tous ceux qui croient au
centre y trouveront leur place et que
personne n'aura besoin de renier ni son
histoire ni son identité et qu'il n'a
pas à se définir par rapport aux autres
mais par rapport au plus profond de ce
qu'il a constitué le mouvement démocrate
affirme son offre de dialogue de
coopération de travail en commun de
rapprochement de démarche unitaire
d'unités j'ai suivi une gradation
peut-être est-ce la gradation du temps à
tous ceux qui s'inscriront dans la
reconnaissance des vertus du centre de
la vie politique française
à une condition que le centre soit le
centre
qu'il s'assume qu'il soit fier de ce
qu'il est autrement il étonnait rate une
copie et personne ne choisit la copie on
va droit à l'original
alors je veux répondre je veux répondre
à une question insidieuse
j'entendais des journalistes hier
j'avais l'oreille qui traînait qui
disait c'est impossible de toute façon
parce que bayrou et borloo de leader
pour ne pas dire deux crocodiles n'ont
pas dans le même marigot c'est trop
petit disons dans le même estuaire dans
le même mille dans la même amazon 2
c'est un de trop
et bien je vous le dis si cette démarche
est accepté et j'ai confiance qu'elle le
sera dans le respect réciproque des uns
par rapport aux autres et dans le
respect de leur histoire et de leur
identité
si cette démarche est acceptée il n'ya
elie n'y aura aucun problème de
leadership
nous sommes deux dit on vous dit que
c'est trop et moi je vous dis que ce
n'est pas assez
je serais heureux le jour où nous serons
des dizaines de leaders fier d'eux mêmes
de leur histoire et ce sera pour moi une
fierté parce que je veux vous le dire où
vous le rappeler si nous n'avions pas
été là pendant ces dix années à mener
ces combats parfois difficile parfois ce
que victorieux le centre n'existerait
plus parce que sa disparition était
programmée par les forces puissantes qui
nous entoure nous l'avons sauver
le centre nous l'avons sauver tous
ensemble en portant le drapeau quand
plus personne n'y croyait et que les
autres étaient partis
soudry pont où ils voulaient nous
entraîner nous avons résisté et nous
avons tel combat et même nous avons
failli le gagner eh bien je ne demande
nous ne demandons nous qui l'avons
sauver qu'une seule chose c'est qu'il
s'affirme et qu'il grandisse et qu'ils
sachent enfin qui il est et où il va et
qu'au lieu de bornes et ses ambitions à
être la roue de secours ou l'allié d'un
puissant voisin qui domine le camp il
accepte lui même de regarder en face la
seule perspective qui vaille c'est à
dire la victoire dans notre pays
allez vous
alors me direz vous il y à l'élection
présidentielle et bien je vous le dis
tranquillement le jour venu le jour de
l'élection présidentielle s'il ya
plusieurs candidats
ce n'est pas si facile de devenir
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
jeudi sans confidences s'il ya plusieurs
candidats et bien marielle de sarnez en
a fait la proposition
nous organiserons les primaires du
centre et le centre aura son candidat
écoutez moi bien signalé primaire du
centre
si ces projets ces personnalités accepte
d'entrer en confrontation
eh bien peut-être ou à coup sûr le
centre aura-t-il enfin candidat
et cette fois ci tous les leaders du
centre soutiendront le candidat du
centre
et peut-être cette fois et peut-être
cette fois ce candidat soutenu par les
siens au lieu d'être combattue par les
siens ce candidat gagnera-t-il et il n'y
a rien de plus sain que d'accepter cette
idée diversité de leader le jour venu
sélection du meilleur d'entre eux
sélection par tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans ce courant et il n'y
a rien à craindre
il n'y a que les faibles qui craignent
la compétition
allons on verra des personnalités
diverses et des talents des orientations
on en débattra est le meilleur le
meilleur pour un temps le meilleur
s'imposera et on portera ou la meilleure
alors la meilleure ou le meilleur
s'imposera et on portera le flambeau
avec une idée c'est de le transmettre
c'est ça que nous avons toujours voulu
faire c'est pour ça qu'on est là pour ça
que le mouvement démocrate a été créé et
ce centre unis on en aura le plus grand
et le plus urgent besoin pour les
échéances qui viennent on en aura besoin
pour les échéances locales jeudi à
l'avance constituer des équipes aussi
large que possible mais par pitié penser
que ce sont les candidats qui font les
bonnes équipes et que évidemment les
bonnes équipes soutiennent les candidats
après et donc mettez vous en recherche
j'allais dire en chasse mettez-vous en
recherche de tous ceux et de toutes
celles qui sur le terrain sont capables
de porter pas seulement notre étiquette
je me fiche des étiquettes mais notre
vision notre manière d'être notre
identité génétique qui est chaque fois
qu'on le peut de se faire un devoir de
tirer la vie civique et la vie politique
vers le haut au lieu de perpétuellement
la faire tomber et s'effondrer bear le
bain des passions et des détestations
et des vulgarités
parce que je considère qu'il doit en
être des responsables politiques comme
des instituteurs de la troisième
république qui n'avait pas besoin de
multiplier les leçons de morale
théorique pour transmettre la leçon de
morale c'était leur vie c'était par
l'exemple qu'il transmettait ce qu'ils
croyaient et bien je demande qu en
politique nous soyons les porteurs
inlassable de cet idéal là nous sommes
ceux qui veulent tirer la vie politique
vers le haut au lieu de la faire
s'effondrer comme on y assiste tous les
jours dans les débats politiques de
notre pauvre pays abandonnés par ceux
qui croient à quelque chose et livré à
ceux qui ne croient plus à rien
on en a besoin pour les élections
locales et on va en avoir besoin de
cette force du centre unis on va en
avoir besoin pour les élections
européennes
et c'est sur ce point que je voudrais
achevé mon propos n'ont pas seulement
parce que nous aimons les députés
européens qui sont dans nos rangs vous
pouvez les applaudir ya nathalie
griesbeck robert rochefort marielle de
sarnez au premier rang de cette salle et
jean luc bennahmias sous les caméras au
centre
alors nous allons en avoir besoin
naturellement pour défendre des sièges
des personnalités qui le méritent mais
ça n'est pas l'essentiel
nous allons en avoir besoin pour
proposer une vision différente et
originale de l'avenir européen du destin
européen
c'est de ça qu'on jeu que je voudrais
vous dire un mot parce que j'ai
l'impression que le débat européen
ces gars trop souvent dans un labyrinthe
duquel on ne sortira pas alors je vais
vous dire des choses étranges que vous
me pardonnerez vous avez de l'indulgence
pour moi mais déjà assez souvent arrivé
de vous dire des choses étranges
jean marie vanlerenberghe hausse les
sourcils au premier rang non mais il
peut les os et aux parce que et donc et
qu' on est en train de dire il faut
faire un pas fédéral et guy verhofstadt
hier dont vous avez bien compris que
quand on se pose la question de savoir
quel sera le leader européen que les
forces politiques européennes foudre ont
proposé à leurs concitoyens de toute
l'europe pour être la figure de l'union
européenne pour être le président de la
commission et lui après les élections
européennes par les députés européens
vous avez bien compris que nous pensions
nous avions le sentiment j'avais le
sentiment on en débattra mais qu'il
avait les qualités nécessaires pour
l'expérience nécessaire disant chef de
gouvernement proposait pour être le
président de la commission par jacques
chirac et le chancelier allemand
ensemble est récusé par les anglais
parce que trop peu européen
guy verhofstadt parce qu'il a cette
expérience parce qu'il est d'un pays la
flandre où l'on sait bien ce que sont
les tensions d'identité et que à la tête
de la belgique pendant dix ans exploit
unique au monde
il a réussi à vaincre ces tensions de
dissolution et à faire vivre et
travailler et s'estimer ces communautés
différentes et ses mouvements politiques
différents par cette expérience par ses
dons personnels
c'est pas rien de parler toutes les
langues de l'europe pour faire la
campagne mais il va falloir aller devant
les les micros et les caméras de
télévision à mon avis ils aiment ça
d'ailleurs
et donc pour défendre ses idées ses
projets donc vous avez bien compris que
sa présence ici n'était pas fortuite que
nous avions des idées pour le moment où
il va falloir désigner un candidat à la
présidence de la commission européenne
pour représenter ces grands courants de
liberté et de démocratie qui sont au
centre de la vie politique européenne
avec une idée exigeante de l'avenir
européen
là vous n'avez le droit d'applaudir je
crois
merci pour lui mais c'est à lui qu'il
conviendra de répondre mais même qui
verhofstadt a dit ça il vient d'écrire
un livre avec cohn bendit qu'il nous a
apporté qui va sortir dans quelques
jours pour défendre cette idée de boules
europe ça s'appelle bien même lui a dit
il faut un pas fédéral
moi je vais vous dire quelque chose
d'autre la fédération des états nations
européens
elles existent parce que quand un
ensemble d'états nations à un parlement
élu au suffrage universel une
organisation exécutive qui bientôt va
dépendre des sélections une banque
centrale est une monnaie commune
je voudrais bien qu'on m'explique ce cas
les d'autre qu'une fédération
l'europe est une fédération d'ores et
déjà j'allais dire accompli selon moi il
n'ya quasi rien à changer dans les
textes mais il ya une vérité à défendre
c'est que cette fédération pour
l'instant elle n'est pas démocratique ou
pas suffisamment dmca mais que les
citoyens européens
y'a pas un citoyen hors pair pas un sur
mille qui pensent qu'ils soient informés
de ce que sont les débats au parlement
européen la faute à tout le monde
les médias ont leur part de
responsabilité mais les citoyens aussi
parce que s'il y avait une demande il y
aurait une offre qui a pu
les gens se gardent d'informer les
peuples de ce dont on va discuter vous
souvenez de mes vieilles marottes
marielle me les reproches assez souvent
j'ai défendu pendant longtemps devons
vous l'idée qu'il fallait publier dans
les journaux tous les mois l'ordre du
jour des débats
les sujets dont on allait parler au
parlement européen voit la commission
qu'est-ce qui était sur la table parce
que le jour où l'on saura de quoi on va
parler vous verrez se mobiliser des
associations des citoyens des groupes de
citoyens
il ne manque qu'une seule chose à
l'europe pour être acceptée acceptée par
les citoyens parce que je pense qu'au
fond d'eux mêmes
l'immense majorité d'entre eux a la
conviction profonde que ce en europe
point de salut tous
mais ce qui manque à l'europe pour être
non seulement accepté mais soutenus pour
être aimé c'est que les citoyens est un
accès une connaissance une compréhension
une possibilité d' influence une
possibilités d'engagement sur les
décisions que l'union européenne prend
en leur nom et donc le grand sujet de
l'avenir européen
ça n'est pas tant le pas fédéral il est
fait depuis longtemps c'est la
démocratisation des institutions qui
pour l'instant sont opaques et fermé et
que nous qui aimons l'europe avons envie
d'ouvrir et de donner accès aux citoyens
et je défends une seule idée pour
conclure cette démocratisation elle va
être acquise le jour où les débats
électoraux concernant l'europe donneront
la certitude à chacun de ceux qui va
voter que son vote va permettre de
choisir celui ou celle qui va s'exprimer
dirigé influence et coordonnée faire
coopérer ensemble les états européens et
les institutions c'est la première chose
il y en a une deuxième que je demande
qui est très simple je vous assure que
c'est une révolution
ça ne coûte pas un euro faut pas changer
une ligne de texte c'est que le conseil
européen qui réunit les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement où les décisions se
prennent au lieu de se dérouler en
catimini dans des salles fermées avec
des gens qui font des échanges sous la
table se déroule en public sous l'oeil
des caméras de télévision afin qu'on
sache de quoi il parle ce qu'il décide
et quelles sont les positions que chacun
défend réellement
ça n'empêchera pas la diplomatie avant
de débattre
ils discuteront ils auront leurs sherpas
qui se promèneront de capitale en
capitale pour préparer la réaction à la
position qu éventuellement le président
de la république française le chancelier
allemand
le premier ministre britannique le chef
du gouvernement italien ou espagnol
prendront ça ne changera rien aux
besoins d'entente entre les états ça
n'aura qu'une vertu ça donnera aux
citoyens la certitude que c'est leur
affaire qu'au lieu d'être
la sphère des initiés là haut
à bruxelles comme on dit injustement
c'est leur affaire et nous avons manqué
une chance formidable songer à ce
qu'aurait été le conseil européen où on
aurait débattu de la guerre en irak
parce que là vous auriez vu se former
une opinion publique européenne parce
que il y avait autant d'italiens et
d'anglais et de portugais et d'espagnol
qui étaient opposés à l'intervention en
irak qu'il y avait deux français et
d'allemands qui était opposé et on
aurait vu alors ses opinions publiques
adhérer à la position juste défendu
cette fois-là par jacques chirac et on
aurait vu en débat d'opinion publique
européenne et l'europe au lieu d'être
une chose d incarner lointaine qui prend
des décisions sans qu'on sache quand ni
comment ni qui ni d'ailleurs ce qu'elle
décide ni pourquoi cette europe là elle
serait devenue un ensemble politique et
civique
eh bien je fais en tout cas pour moi du
débat sur la démocratisation des
institutions européennes d'ores et déjà
fédéral je fais du débat de la
démocratisation le sujet qu'entre nous
nous allons nous mettre sur la table à
l'intention de nos partenaires du parti
démocrate et du groupe ld
au parlement européen et des citoyens
européens qui seront invités à voter à
se prononcer pour nous lors des
élections européennes
nous allons porter la vision d'une
europe rendu aux citoyens européens
parce que il le mérite
ils le méritent les citoyens et n
l'europe mérite qu'on aime
nous avons passé trois journées
formidables que tout le monde décrivait
comme la journée de tous les dangers
parce que probablement ce qui
formulaient ce jugement ne mesurais pas
à quel point nous sommes heureux d'être
ensemble
bien sûr
bien sûr il y as en notre sein diversité
de sensibilité et c'est normal diversité
de projets pour l'avenir et c'est normal
c'est le réel qui va départager tout ça
nous nous avons besoin d'abord
d'affirmer notre volonté notre
enracinement notre identité et d'être
ouvert nous choisirons une chose je vous
le promets nous choisirons ce qui sera
le plus utile au pays dans les moments
difficiles qu'il va traverser
c'est ça le choix que nous allons faire
j'ai été personnellement j'ai été très
heureux de du grand débat qu'on a eue
hier soir de la qualité remarquable des
échanges sur les grands sujets qui se
sont exprimées tout au long de ces
journées
je voudrais remercier monsieur chebi
président du parti président de la haute
autorité du parti républicain tunisien
d'avoir passé ces trois jours avec nous
je voudrais remercier les parlementaires
députés
il était là dans l'ensemble du groupe
thierry robert et jean lassalle
les sénateurs qui vont passer ses
journées avec mu les maires de grandes
villes le maire de talence le maire de
mont-de-marsan le maire de saint brieuc
c'était des journées formidables que
nous avons vécu ensemble parce qu'elles
n'avaient qu'un seul sujet comment nous
qui avons fondé et défendu le mouvement
démocrate en france allons-nous être le
plus utile à notre pays c'est la voie
que nous avons choisie
merci beaucoup